[Musique]
c'est le restaurant dont tout le monde
parle ici à Versailles le petit bouillon
vient d'ouvrir ici dans la cité royale
il est tout juste midi et il y a déjà
beaucoup de monde qui attend pour entrer
à l'intérieur
[Musique]
la salle est remplie dès l'ouverture et
si on retrouve des clients venus des
environs mais également des touristes on
a visité le château de Versailles et
donc c'était l'occasion de venir sur sur
un restaurant on avait entendu parler
des bouillons ouais du principe de
bouillon et on connaissait pas donc
comme il y en avait un là on est venu là
tout simplement c'est le bouche à
oreille tout simplement
et moi je suis déjà venue je trouve ça
très bien les prix rapport qualité-prix
c'est excellent le restaurant ouvert le
16 décembre dernier réalise aujourd'hui
plus de 250 couverts par service le
directeur adieux embaucher 30 personnes
pour répondre à la demande toujours
croissante
[Musique]
bon appétit Michael c'est excellent nous
avons rien inventé puisque c'est en 1855
que Pierre-Louis Duval avait créé le
premier bouillon dans les halles où il
faisait manger les ouvriers idéales en
1900 les choses se sont vraiment
démocratisées et en l'occurrence il y
avait à peu près 250 bouillons sur la
capitale on retrouve tous les plats à
l'ancienne on va commencer par les
entrées l’œuf mimosa l'os à moelle la
terrine du chef qui est une terrine à
l'ancienne après vous allez passer sur
les plats traditionnels qui sont la
blanquette de veau le bœuf bourguignon
[Musique]
de mon côté ce midi j'ai commandé une
fondue de fromage au miel à 3,40 une
blanquette de veau à 12,50 € et une
mousse au chocolat en dessert à 3,50 €
prix total 19,40 sans boisson à la fin
du service c'est l'heure du bilan pour
les clients
[Musique]
même dans le centre de Versailles vous
avez pas des prix comme ça très bien
franchement alors moi ce que j'avais
c'était comme Madame un poulet avec les
endives tout était parfait brégé comme
il faut ça correspond tout à fait à nos
attentes on va très bien manger
que dire les places sont très bons on a
dû manger sans compter les boissons
grosso modo pas pour 20 euros par
personne c'est quand même relativement
correct avec un service quand même très
agréable des gens très sympathiques il
est 14h c'est la fin du service ici au
bouillon de Versailles quand vous pouvez
le voir il y a beaucoup moins de monde
ici si vous voulez venir à déguster le
restaurant est ouvert à tous les jours
sauf le lundi à bon appétit